place stockfish I could play stockfish
I'll play sock fish and bullets
ignoring the 26 pending challenges who
said that looking low Jonas I just I
want a a difficult opponent oh I'll just
play one bullet came against tonic fish
it won't take too long okay let's play
stock first level one I know it most
quickly I'm not gonna blunder anything
hopefully trade stuff trade some more
stuff okay so I'm just up a piece let's
trade more stuff I'm taking this kind of
serious thing because I know it's tricky
sometimes
oh I had an idea
I should've played 94 regretful let's
play this 94 coming let's starts playing
well when it's down material it's normal
I'm just gonna pile up why is it being
annoying yeah okay let's take stuff
trade more stuff yeah it's moving really
quickly but I'm gonna beat it but not
sell me on it okay there we go
okay what a game we almost got still me
that but not quite okay can I play it in
hyper bullets wonder oh I could
oh dear this is my life now
[Music]
okay let's play hyper bullets ah hyung a
bishop I didn't take it I got a knight
Billiton tickets what's playing so
annoyingly stop hurting me
this is bad this is really bad
God promoted to a rock just to humiliate
me that's so sad
okay rematch I'm gonna beat it at some
point a 3d playing your colleague said
it wasn't my setup
well I hung a pawn why is it playing
well now okay come upon ooh dying meat
don't make me go I hung a queen
Chuck Chuck the whole I got mated ah I
was so close to me - that's so close to
meet but it wasn't me oh we met no
hyperbole it's not easy analysis thing
dole I wanted to play each five no let's
stop it okay just have to liquidate
quickly no live resign this was really
bad and you
anything okay let's play English a3 okay
oh this is a good line for white cuz I'm
gonna pawn what oh that's a move
Wow what a move 84 it wants to meet me
again stop it and miss me in one
oh it's just torturing me oh no I don't
want to analyze okay let's focus on
winning
you're not flagging it's so fast what's
playing a reasonable game why is it so
good
okay now let's plunger in kind of this
is very entertaining ah oh it's a draw
I drew okay I drew I drew oh thanks Jim
do you illusion okay he's like hot one
draw I was trying to meet at first I
thought that four is me but it's not me
oh gee oh no that wasn't it me either
I guess I didn't have meet Brooks always
defending okay
rematch it doesn't show my score I guess
that's a good thing though clay of
London haven't played on London yet it's
dumb 9 each final oh my gosh I'm how is
it so good I can't play this move yeah
it's so fast well I want a queen it's
nice I'm so down on time
[Music]
donal it took my queen a high resign why
I want a queen - Sonia Lane gifting subs
thanks Sonia but I have to focus okay
good omen sub gifts let's go focus focus
focus over here 109
okay focus focus
no I lost a thing no I lost another
thing ah keep losing things
Chuck promote the pawn die got me that
oh I think Sonia for gifting a sub to
our Resnick's Lulu Lulu food shadow - Oh
moon my throne or indie writer and
secret ex - this is so devastating the
sub slightly soothe the pain but this is
really devastating I haven't I've okay
I'm not getting adopted but this is
really not easy g5 it's taking a play
out of my book okay
it keeps moving fast God needed me
oh I don't know what to do I know what
to do it's so good
it keeps defending stuff but sometimes
it doesn't defend stuff like their and
that's okay you five I should just be
winning this now mmm let's play this
move but then it's it's very resourceful
let's take that it's so resourceful stop
it let's take that haha I got nervous I
was up like three pieces - oh my gosh
okay
I'm gonna beat it I'm gonna beat it I'm
g5 shenanigans again yes okay smoothly
[Music]
die and it wins because stupid mating
material oh my gosh oh oh it's so fast
oh that was a close one too
I was up a queen for a night I had two
pawns okay I'm gonna take it down I
think maybe I don't know already up a
pawn I feel like I just have to play
differently
oh man it's doing good things again this
is so frustrating cuz it's just torture
it's playing around with me
I get Miss Mayton one I think at some
points it found me than one
hey it's Neil is that Neil I think
that's Neil welcome back
oh it's funny Neil was I think you were
in the chat earlier on YouTube for the
Karen's Cup and you told me to stream at
this time and now I'm streaming I'm
trying to yeah if you're just joining
I'm trying to take down sawfish level 1
in bullet it's not easy I got close like
once I think I can't like spend so much
time though I just have to move quickly
ooh oh man ok this is bad I'm getting
tilted and I can't get tilted because
the computer doesn't like fuel tilt it
just takes advantage of my tilts now I
play I played one oh and I won I think
pretty easily so
well what is this is trying to meet me
no it's not okay
such garbage opening okay let's punish
it Wow somehow it tricked me
I'm worse now these moves are so
confusing it's not using any time either
okay new strategy I'm gonna be super
solid and move super quickly and not
plunge or anything except the pawn and
the Knights move let's just attack maybe
I took all my pawns please don't see me
this is so painful I don't know what to
do
maybe I should take a break I should
take my my anger out on other victims
but no I have to okay I have to play I
have to win at least one game is this
beatable oh it wants to fishing oh no it
not even a fishing pole was this lights
trapped
let's go let's go oh okay so I just have
to me this
I told me I knew it was that simple
let's go with 10 seconds left - I just
have to mean it
not so easy actually was a really
frustrating take that future overlords
yeah take that now I just quit while I'm
ahead
right sometime really behind Alexa play
heck no by maladroit happy now huh good
try
Oh rage quits rage quit after a win that
would be that would be uh uh something
Thomas with a twitch prime sub do I
rematch let's let's try and adopt it
let's let's win another game I think I
understand how to beat it now I just
have to meet it yeah stop taking my
pawns I just have to meet it check oh
that's not me it's yes that's me yes I
won again I went two in a row cuz I made
it it
I was about to flag there two lights
were confusing let's go let's two down
okay adoption time
yak its stock fish is tilted now it's
not used to losing rematch rematch let's
go my night doing oh oh I suppose I just
needed to promote another pawn under
promotion - that was wicked what was
that slow-motion replay promotion night
what is this who programs this okay well
two and a half of the three last three
games a bad one more
oh the trout might Bishop so devious but
it didn't take my bishop okay it's
addicting its addicting one more winning
and I'll stop now this is a very solid
game so far again I wanted to trial a
bishop oh this is so beautiful
Queens entering the game because I can't
think long term it can't think five
moves ahead that's so nice that's so
nice ooh I beat it in 15 seconds
do I dare challenge it to alter bullets
I should I should challenge its ultra
bullet